hey youtubers is Charlie awesome news
they confirm Planet Hulk warbound
for thor ragnarok so i'll explain what
the director said if you're new to the
channel I do Marvel videos every week
I'm doing a spider-man giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video so I'm
going to play this clip from the trailer
just for context I have to change the
audio just for licensing reasons Led
Zeppelin is not what you would call a
youtube safe its main event time
[Applause]
we know each other he's a friend from
work
most of you probably know that a large
portion of thor ragnarok is inspired by
Planet Hulk from the comic book so I'll
explain a little bit of that story
because that's where the warbound group
comes from there have been a bunch of
changes from the comics but there is a
gladiator arena that they're all forced
to fight in a group of them band
together out of mutual respect just
because they're all badasses the Hulk
eventually gains their respect through
his victories and through their mutual
sense of honour and they become warbound
and later follow Hulk as he goes for his
revenge during world war hulk which was
the comic book arc that came right after
Planet Hulk so I'll explain those
storylines and how that fits into Thor
Ragnarok the movie because they're not
doing the entire planet whole story and
some of the characters have changed well
you don't see in that clip or the
warbound characters that were confirmed
by the director so the director himself
said that he had a cameo as Korg
he's a member of the cronin race the
rock looking people the one that Thor
beat the crap out of during Thor the
dark world if you remember that
[Applause]
I accept your surrender anyone else so
what he said is is it during the movie
he serves as a warm-up fight for Thor
before he runs into his friend the Hulk
so you can kind of see the progression
here it's like a video game he works his
way up through a couple minor battles
then all of a sudden he has to fight
their most deadly warrior their most
popular fighter in out pops the Hulk and
he's like oh my god yes you know you get
this reaction in fact as funny as that
seems who wants to lay bets that a
different version of this scene actually
made it into the final cut of the movie
they're editing it right now but just
because you see something in a trailer
doesn't mean that it's going to end up
in the final cut of the movie so the
same thing happens with the whole during
the planet whole comic book storyline he
slowly fights his way up to bigger and
badder fighters but the other big
warbound character that was confirmed by
the director in the movie was meek who's
a member of the brood race so if you
read Planet Hulk you're like wait a
minute are they going to do the meek
storyline even if they're only doing
part of Planet Hulk is he going to be
some kind of crazy traitor
so the meek character is kind of a
tragic figure in the Planet Hulk
storyline the planet they're fighting on
in the trailer that's accurate to the
comics is ruled over by this warlord
called the Red King that just forces
them to fight for everyone's amusement
like a mad Caesar if you're not familiar
with the mad caesar's they're really fun
if you're big history buff but
eventually Spartacus style if you
haven't seen that movie that's another
great movie - he fights his way up the
ladder in the arena gains everyone's
respect the respect of his fellow
gladiators there's a big coup and he
seemingly liberate the planet there's an
accident he witnesses the death of his
wife and child or he at least believes
that they're dead while he was on the
car he fell in love with a fellow
gladiator
they had a child together but when he
witnesses their death he decides to take
revenge on the people that he believes
are responsible which he thinks of the
Illuminati so he goes back to earth and
that becomes the world war hulk
storyline the maddest you've ever seen
the Hulk in the matter he gets the
stronger he gets and it is a limitless
thing he even seems like he eats a
couple of Earth's heroes as he's ripping
through them like tissue paper so this
whole time the warbound have sworn
allegiance to him and his cause but it
was all part of this big turn where Greg
puck and the Marvel people wanted to pit
hulk against his friends so that's kind
of what's happening in here you're
getting a little bit from world war hulk
and a little bit from planet look where
he has to fight his friends so if you
wonder why that is
it's because they explained that Hulk
has been on this planet fighting in the
arena for a long time ever since the end
of that first Avengers film so we're
talking more than a year that's enough
time for him to win the respect of all
these people become this crazy gladiator
and it's gone to his head they call him
a god of Sekar he is the world breaker
Hulk just completely crazy even though
they changed the Red King character to
the Grandmaster who doesn't really come
off as that evil Jeff Goldblum does not
seem evil in the trailer so in the
comics the Red King was very sinister
the Grandmaster is more of a cosmic Game
Master he just cares for really good
games but the other members of the
warbound in the comics are his wife Kara
the one who ends up dying Ella we hear
om Korg meek who are both in the movie
like I explained Archie and moong so not
all of them survive and obviously the
director only confirmed Corrigan meek so
there could be other Easter eggs for the
other warbound members but I don't think
they're going to be doing Hulk's wife I
don't think they're going to be doing
Hulk's son Skaar although they'd be a
lot of conspiracy theories as to the
movie comes out like he was on the car
for a long time is a pretty good chance
that one of these women out here could
be holding his whole child but we've
established that Hulk just keeps getting
madder in matter he's been on stack R
for a long time so it's gone to his head
so he is in full-blown warrior mode but
the fun part of this is that Thor is so
powerful as an Asgardian just his own
natural physiology makes them that much
stronger that he can soak a lot of hope
damage without getting crumpled into a
soda
and like any other person would if Hawk
were to punch a normal human being they
would explode like a watermelon but Thor
does experience a version of this rage
that you see in the Hulk's eyes it's
called warrior madness where they just
go completely out of control they
actually did it in unworthy Thor where
the version of Thor who's lost his
hammer he's become unworthy finds that
the ultimate Thor's hammer from a
different universe is available so beta
ray bill comes to help him out he's
being held captive by the collector Thor
just completely goes nuts and frees
himself from this electric prison this
is how much damage he can so you have to
remember that the collector has some of
the most advanced technology in the
galaxy so if anybody were to touch these
bars they would get fried in an instant
so as he sort of Hulk's out breaks out
of prison he goes into this warrior
madness and starts thinking to himself I
feel that berserker rage take control of
me feel my mind consumed with wanton
wrath feel my friends throat being
crushed beneath my hands in gods help me
I do not care so just look at the look
in his eyes here this is what's
happening to the Hulk in this moment
right here in real life in human history
Vikings had a version of that there was
a warrior trance that certain warriors
would go into by drinking a special
concoction you have to imagine drinking
say like 10 Red Bulls at the same time
with a bunch of alcohol so your
adrenaline and your pain tolerance is
cranked way up you just don't feel as
much damage and you just send them into
battle like a one-man wrecking crew like
steer clear because he's going to be
swinging at anything that comes into his
field of vision so that's what's
happening to thor here that's kind of
what's happening with the hulk in the
arena so in this scene it does seem like
thor has his wits about him like he's
like oh my god i'm have to fight my
friend here because he's gone completely
crazy but while moments like this happen
thor does really get into it too but we
haven't seen that many Thor movies where
he's gone super crazy I think just
because they don't want to scare
children but this is what he looks like
when he goes completely off the chain so
hopefully we'll see a version of this in
the movie but they did say that they
were leaning more on comedy and thor
ragnarok so if you're a big Planet Hulk
aficionado just be sure to look out for
more warbound Easter eggs you know let
me know in the comments do you think
that they'll work the Red
is an easter egg in the background of
the movie because it's such a big
antagonist in the comic book in Planet
Hulk the storyline is so important to
this movie you feel like they try to
work it as much stuff as possible but
there's all these things coming together
from the comics in this moment here you
have Grand Master
Jack Kirby Celestials eternal stuff
going on in the background a very cosmic
stuff then you have the slightly more
grounded Planet Hulk gladiator storyline
with him being forced to fight in the
arena he and Thor battling it out and
then the more Thor elements of the movie
where you're actually going up against
Ella and the Ragnarok stuff so if
there's any Marvel movie in phase 3
besides Infinity Ward's it has the most
Easter eggs from the comics it's
probably going to be thor ragnarok
because they're drawing from so many big
iconic things and that doesn't even get
into the idea of Thor reforging or
getting a new version of his hammer do
you think they're going to reforge yeol
near as is or do you think they're going
to reforge it as ultimate Thor's hammer
with the axe on the back of it and it'll
be like an extra hardcore version of the
hammer that he's been using so just
think about that and then look at this
Infinity Ward concept with him next to
rocket he's wielding an extra big
version of what looks like the ultimate
Thor hammer but you don't get a good
look at it so I think they're trying not
to be too spoilery but that's no
speculation at this point I have a
feeling they'll do their best to keep a
new hammer out of any of the trailers
because at some point he does have to
get a version of the hammer back so I
know a lot of you have been asking for
an infinity war video for Scarlet Witch
and vision because they've been filming
a bunch of scenes I'll try to get that
out sometime this weekend but there's a
Black Panther footage video that I need
to do they showed up a whole bunch of
footage and they just wrap that film so
I'll post that video on Saturday
congratulations to the latest spider-man
giveaway winner sharp shot please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for that to post
you can click here to learn all about
Adam warlock and the guardians of the
galaxy franchise and you can click here
for a brand new game of Thrones promo
breakdown thank you so much for watching
sometimes five I'll see you guys in the
next